hey guys today we're breaking down the
insane details in my
academia chapter 283 some of which were
really easy to miss
last week i did a spoiler review of this
chapter but this video right here is
more of an analysis
of certain details that i thought were
pretty interesting to start things off
this chapter picks up where chapter 280
left off
when the pro heroes were flying in to
take down gigantomachia
this includes the likes of sunita gang
orca
majestic and several others at this
moment when they were flying in
machia had just taken the drug which
momo created and the intention
was that it would put him to sleep
however in this chapter
we see that his rampage has only gotten
worse and he's activated
a previously unknown transformation
quirk
looking at his hands here he has these
enormous claws on each finger
which are perfect for just tearing up
the surrounding environment around him
when we compare these hands to what his
hands look like in previous chapters
i mean he definitely has way more
destructive capability now than he did
back then
in addition we see a ton of students
were directly
in his path not to mention gang orca who
seems to be flung around like a ragdoll
whilst the students were lifted to
safety by majestic
we see this wave of destruction
approaching the magic hero
honestly like i think there's a zero
percent chance that he has survived this
but his sacrifice it kind of reminds me
of that moment in man of steel when
superman's dad died i don't know it just
really really reminds me of that
when we look at this landscape the
students who were saved by majestic were
brought over to this location
and then the remaining heroes were
caught up in macchia's destructive path
over here
if they can survive that then good job
because you know it wouldn't it wouldn't
have been easy
but as i said in my q a the other day i
expect that many of these heroes
will not make it really hoping that
tamaki survives though above everyone
else
because if he doesn't i mean miriam is
just going to be on the war path he is
not going to stop
until shigaraki is dead till maki is
dead he would even fight them quirkless
i bet
another interesting thing to note is
tokyomi using dark shadow to keep a
bunch of medics safe from all the
falling rocks caused by makia
way back in chapter 273 which is 10
chapters ago now
fat gum saw tokyomi and hawks and told
them where the medics were
so that explains why they're at this
medical site if you look at the doctors
themselves i mean they're pretty much
identical either that or they all have
to be bald for some reason but
my assumption is that there is just one
medic and he has a quirk that lets him
split himself into many copies
possibly that or horukoshi just couldn't
be bothered to draw different looking
medics
i mean either way it works before we
move on to the next thing
i need to point out that mushroom girl
from class 1b
i mean she asks a very relevant question
which is shouldn't the sedative have
kicked in by now
previously we never had a concrete
timeline as to
how long the drug would take right so we
knew that it was implied that he'd fall
asleep pretty quickly
and then obviously momo said it would
kick in the faster machine moves around
well now we have confirmation from
mushroom girl just straight up
it should have worked by now it should
have kicked in um so that is our
confirmation right there
couple that with the fact that now
machia he's stronger than ever and he's
got this you know
his arms his hands are transforming into
these giant claws
he's never been more scary than he is
right now so make of that what you will
you know the drug should have kicked in
maybe it has maybe it has
but it's just not the drug we think i
know many people do not want to believe
momo is the traitor
and you know what i don't want to
believe it either i don't think she has
to be
but until this drug has the intended
effect that it was supposed to have
or that we were told it was supposed to
have you know i can't just drop it you
know it's possible
she is the traitor anyway perhaps one of
the most interesting details of this
chapter
was the different expressions we see
from the league of villain members
as machia tears through a city killing
thousands of innocent people in the
process
we get a look at spinner's face and that
face to me is someone who's really
considering if they're doing the right
thing
um we saw back in the overhaul arc that
spinner
back then he questioned whether the
villains are following stains ideals
and this is another one of those moments
would stain really want giganto machia
you know killing all these people and
destroying cities in the process
would stain want that i don't think so
that makes it all the more hilarious to
compare spinner's face
to darby's face because if you guys
remember darby is also a loyal
follower of stain and when you look at
his face he's just radiating with
happiness
with all this carnage many chapters ago
debbie said to hawkes that he would be
the one to make stains will a reality
well yeah i doubt this is stains will
but whatever
going back to the main battlefield now
deku and bakugou have an interaction
that was totally different from what i
thought it was
so what happened was deku shoots off
away from back ago and towards shigaraki
and last week i thought you know this is
what the translation said
i thought bakugou was calling out to him
kind of you know telling him not to
sacrifice his life
going up against the demon that is
shigaraki but instead
the panel starts with bakago being left
in the dust you know not even knowing
what to say
and then when he does say something he
just curses in frustration
this makes it seem like he's more
concerned about being left behind by
deku in terms of their growth as a hero
as rivals you know they always want to
one-up each other but it seems that
bakago is now beginning to realize
that deku is just that little bit better
than him remember
nearly 10 chapters ago bakugou was
monologuing about how he isn't going to
be left behind
and how he can't afford to lose to deku
not to mention the fact that he took
issue with midoriya being the main
character as he called it
this just seems like he's taking issue
with deku surpassing him more than
anything else
but do let me know what you guys think
on this one is he concerned about deku
or is it a mixture of both is he both
concerned and also
upset that deku is overtaking him
another cool detail was related to
shigaraki
and if you've read the chapter you'll
know that his body finally began to
suffer some blowback
for using all of this power despite
being woken up at just 75
completion the moment when he suffers
the blowback from his quirk
it's a bit too gory for me to show right
now but let's just say his right arm is
hanging
like some kind of ripped teddy bear as
deku approaches
shiggy asks him what the date is which
is confirmation that this whole time
shiguraki didn't actually know he'd been
woken up early
i don't know about you guys i just
assumed he already knew because it's not
like the heroes were going to show up
coincidentally
on the exact day you were meant to come
out and also we got to remember that
shiguraki woke up on the ground instead
of inside his tank
that should have been a dead giveaway
but yeah for whatever reason
shiguraki never realized that he'd been
let out of the tank early
and so he was asking deku about the date
because he was trying to work out
you know am i at a hundred percent
probably not
undeniably though the best moment of
this chapter was deku activating his
third quark
which is known as float as most of you
know this was possessed by nana shimura
who was the seventh holder of one for
all
and one thing that was really clear in
the official chapter release
was exactly how he was using black whip
in tandem
with this new ability we can see that
he's floating in the air
and using his left arm to hold up the
heroes including ryukyu who is now back
into her human form
with her arm just being totally messed
up after shiguraki did some serious
damage
when she was in her dragon form one
thing you may not have noticed though
is that in deku's right arm he's using
black whip to yank shigaraki into the
sky
what this means is that perhaps the
decay that shigaraki was about to
unleash
well now that he's in the air maybe that
stopped which is good news for heroes
like mirko and president mike
who had literally no way of avoiding the
destruction if it was to come
also by pulling shigeraki with his right
hand he's kind of keeping the villains
separate from everyone else
some of you might have been surprised
that deku activated float
without talking to nana shimura in some
way but when i looked back at chapter
210 which is when black whip was first
introduced
it wasn't until two chapters later that
deku spoke to the fifth user of one for
all
in this situation i reckon it might be a
similar thing in that nana shamura
reaches out to him within a few chapters
we saw how the first user of one for all
was able to talk to deku
despite the fact that deku wasn't
sleeping he wasn't brainwashed or
anything like that so i reckon nana
shimura can do the same thing
the last thing to mention on this
chapter is that the name of the chapter
is 75
and while this refers to shigaraki it
does also refer to deku
and his use of both black whip and float
at the same time
as we know float was formally possessed
by the seventh user
and blackwhip was formally possessed by
the fifth user so
seven five you know 75 it has two
different meanings in this sense
one that refers to deku in his multiple
quirks and one that refers to shigaraki
and him coming out of the tank earlier
but with all that said those were the
details that you may have missed in
chapter 283
don't forget to sub and please like this
video and share it around if you liked
it
and don't forget that part 3 of my war
arc review should be out later this week
peace out